we kicked out of two school  is there anything useful a prison is  just rupees this is beyond basic not  gonna boot your entire generation you  live on your forms you have no idea how  to function like normal people in real  life this is my life you're the most  beautiful girl I've ever seen both make  it useless goofy things just because  something sounds crazy doesn't mean it's  not true I was scared I wouldn't know  how to beat you  did you see MIT I got some of the  question there's something going on here  I don't even know how to begin to  explain that just happen we're looking  for something unusual something  dangerous you'll see something crazy  let's sweep them out right now really  nervous on anything like this stick it  to the man  nothing really  what's a demigod gonna do